bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de suprématie quantique
alors derrière ce terme un peu
grandiloquent se cache une avancée
technologique importante qui a été
annoncé en octobre 2019 par les
laboratoires de recherche de google pour
la première fois un ordinateur quantique
a été capable de faire mieux que les
meilleurs super ordinateurs du monde en
résolvant un problème qu'aucun d'entre
eux n'aurait plus résoudre en pratique
cette étape importante marque la fin
d'une course de vitesse entre google ibm
intel microsoft et quelques autres pour
savoir qui le premier arriverait à faire
cette démonstration de force dans cette
vidéo je vais donc vous expliquer en
quoi consiste cette réalisation
ce qu'elle signifie en pratique est ce
que ça implique pour les développements
futurs de l'informatique quantique mais
expliquons tout d'abord comment
fonctionne un ordinateur quantique et ce
qui le différencie d'un ordinateur
normal dit classique un processeur
d'ordinateur classique stocks et
manipule les données sous forme de beat
un beat c'est une unité élémentaire
d'information qui peut valoir soit 0
soit 1 et que le processeur peut lire et
écrire de façon électronique sous forme
de courant et de tension électrique
toute l'information manipulé par un
ordinateur les donc sous forme de série
2 0 et 2 1 qui permettent de représenter
des nombres des caractères mais aussi
des images de la musique des vidéos etc
or en mécanique quantique vous le savez
peut-être les règles du jeu changent
il est possible de réaliser des systèmes
physiques qui peuvent être dans ce qu'on
appelle un état superposé
vous connaissez sans doute l'image du
chat de schrödinger inquiet en quelque
sorte à la fois mort et vivant et bien
on peut utiliser ce principe pour créer
ce qu'on appelle des bit quantique ou
cubitt qui peuvent stocker l'information
non pas sous forme soit 2 0 soit 2 1
mais comme une superposition des deux
qui peut avoir des proportions variables
alors ici j'utilise ce symbole bizarre
inquiets la notation habituel des
physiciens pour désigner les états
quantiques
précision importante un cubi tu n'es pas
forcément dans un état superposé
il peut très bien être dans un état
purement 0 ou purement 1
on appelle cela des étapes propre
l'intérêt d'utiliser des qubits c'est
que ça permet en quelque sorte de
manipuler les deux états à la fois et
donc de gagner du temps de faire d'une
pierre deux coups en dit comme ça on a
envie de penser qu'un ordinaire
or quantique permet juste d'aller deux
fois plus vite mais regardez ce qui se
passe si on prend plusieurs cubitt
imaginons que dans un processeur
d'ordinateur normal on est trois bits
pour stocker de l'information
au total le processeur à huit états
possibles 0 0 0 0 0 1 0 1 0 0 1 1 et
c'est messi dans un processeur quantique
on a trois cubitt et qu'on arrive à les
manipuler ensemble alors un seul état du
processeur peut représenter une
superposition quantique un mélange des
huit états propres on fait donc d'une
pierre 8 et de façon plus générale si on
na n cubitt on peut s'en servir pour
représenter une superposition de deux
puissants scène et a donc le gain
augmente de façon exponentielle avec le
nombre de cubes it avec 10 kubitz a fait
un facteur 1000 vaincu beat plus d'un
million et c'est l'intérêt d'un
ordinateur quantique c'est donc la
possibilité d'effectuer des calculs
beaucoup plus rapidement en bénéficiant
d'une forme de parallélisme alors
j'insiste sur le côté une forme de
parallélisme parce que j'ai été obligé
de simplifier un ordinateur quantique
c'est pas juste un ordinateur qui va
plus vite et sur lequel on pourrait
faire tourner windows ou alors son jeu
vidéo préféré et s'est même pas non plus
comme d'avoir plein d'ordinateurs en
parallèle à sa disposition
c'est plus compliqué et plus restrictif
que ça c'est plutôt un type particulier
d'ordinateur on devrait même plutôt
parler de processeurs quantique qui ne
fonctionne qu'avec des algorithmes
spécifiques qui ne sont pas ceux des
processeurs classiques et toutes les
choses qu'on a l'habitude de faire avec
un ordinateur classique ne sont pas
susceptibles d'être accéléré avec un
processeur quantique parmi les
algorithmes quantique très prometteur il
ya celui de glover qui permettrait
d'accélérer la recherche dans des bases
de données ce qui est quand même
potentiellement assez utile dans
certaines applications
il ya aussi le fameux algorithme de
shore du nom du mathématicien pictures
qui permet de décomposer un nombre
entier en facteur premier la
décomposition d'un nombre en facteur
premier c'est par exemple calculé que 34
1081 et bien c'est 100 97 x 173 et
trouver ce genre de décomposition est un
problème qui devient de plus en plus
difficile avec un ordinateur classique
quand les nombres deviennent très grand
et d'ailleurs pas mal de protocoles de
sécurité se base sur le fait que si on
choisit des nombreux suffisamment grand
et bien c'est impossible en pratique de
trouver cette décomposition
le souci qu'on pourrait avoir c'est
qu'un ordinateur quantique
disons l'algorithme de schorre pourrait
faire ça beaucoup plus vite et donc
compromettre la sécurité de pas mal de
communication et de transaction
aujourd'hui heureusement on va voir
qu'on en est encore très loin
[Musique]
alors qu a donc réussi à faire google
exactement la première chose qu'il faut
dire c'est que des ordinateurs
quantiques on sait en faire depuis déjà
une vingtaine d'années mais c'est
uniquement dans les labos de recherche
car la plupart ne peuvent résoudre que
des problèmes complètement évident par
exemple réussir une décomposition en
facteur premier avec l'algorithme de
shore mais uniquement pour des nombres
pas trop grand le record actuel c'est 4
millions 88 1459 qui vaut 2010 cette
fois 2027
en 2012 le physicien john presqu'île a
introduit le terme de suprématie
quantique pour désigner le jour où un
ordinateur quantique arriverait pour la
première fois à résoudre un problème
qu'un ordinateur classique ne pourrait
pas résoudre et c'est donc cette étape
que google vient visiblement de franchir
alors deux choses à propos de ce concept
ont déjà le terme est pas génial
suprématie ça a pas des très bonnes
connotation et john presqu'île lui même
reconnaît volontiers a posteriori que la
dénomination est pas terrible mais bon
le terme est resté
l'autre point c'est que cette définition
de la suprématie quantique
ça n'est pas une définition absolue en
théorie un ordinateur classique peut
toujours simuler un ordinateur quantique
et donc résoudre exactement les mêmes
problèmes que lui mais en pratique si le
temps de calcul sur l'ordinateur
classique est monstrueux
et bien c'est là qu'on parle de
suprématie quantique pour atteindre ce
résultat google a fabriqué un processeur
quantique comportant 53 cubitt ce
processeur peut donc en principe
représenter une superposition de deux
puissances 53 états c'est-à-dire environ
dix mille milliards pour démontrer la
suprématie quantique
il leur fallait donc résoudre un
problème impossible à résoudre en
pratique par le meilleur super
ordinateurs actuels alors intuitivement
on pourrait penser que ce soit par
exemple décomposé en facteur premier un
nombre immense et bien non pour des
raisons qu'on verra plus tard
utilisez l'algorithme de schorre était
totalement impossible avec leur système
et ils ont donc choisi un autre problème
pour leur démonstration de force
c'est un problème qu'on appelle
l'échantillonnage d'un circuit quantique
et il a comme particularité d'être assez
artificiel est inutile car il n'y a pas
d'application pratique mais en tant
qu'etat patiente ific pour atteindre la
suprématie quantique et bien il n'y a
pas besoin que ça serve à quelque chose
alors qu'est ce que c'est un circuit
quantique dans un processeur classique
on stocke l'information sous forme de
bille
les 10 et pour les manipuler modifier
leur valeur on utilise des opérations
élémentaires qu'on appelle des portes
logiques
vous en connaissez peut-être quelques
unes la porte non qui inverse la valeur
d'un beat la porte et la porte ou etc
ce sont des opérations logiques qui fixe
la valeur de certains bits en fonction
d'autres tous les calculs que fait un
processeur classique peuvent se résumer
à l'application de porte logique bien
choisis et bien pour un processeur
quantique c'est presque pareil il existe
aussi des opérations qui peuvent
transformer les états des qubits et
qu'on appelle des portes logique
quantique
il en existe tout un tas un beaucoup
plus que des portes logiques classiques
si on prend un groupe de cubic d'une
certaine taille qu'on lui applique une
porte quantique
on le transforme et si on lui applique
toute une série de portes quantique
on forme ce qu'on appelle un circuit
quantique un circuit quantique c'est
donc une série d'opérations qui va
s'appliquer sur un ensemble de cubitt
pour le transformer et modifier son état
alors imaginons qu'on est trois cuite et
un circuit quantique formé d'un certain
nombre de portes successives
supposons également que l'état initial
ça soit simplement l'état 000 un état
propre
après l'application du circuit le
cubique va être dans un état différent a
priori un état superposé qui va être une
super position des huit états propre et
je voulais dit dans une super position
il y à des proportions et donc des
coefficients on va les notés à b c etc
l'application du circuit à transformer
l'état 000 en un état superposé dont les
coefficients vont dépendre du circuit
qu'on applique et si on applique un
autre circuit constitué de différentes
portes quantique pas dans le même ordre
on aura des coefficients différents
maintenant un point essentiel à
comprendre c'est qu'à la fin de
l'opération quand le processeur
quantique et dans un certaine et à la
composition de cet état et bien on la
connaît pas elle s'affiche pas sur un
écran si on veut connaître l'état il
faut le mesurer et la mesure c'est une
opération bien particulière qu'on doit
faire sur le processeur ce qu'on
aimerait quand on fait cette mesure
c'est qu'elle nous donne par exemple les
valeurs des huit coefficient de façon à
ce qu'on sache dans quelle état exact et
le processeur malheureusement en
mécanique quantique ça ne se passe pas
comme ça ce que la mesure va nous donner
c'est un état propre pris au hasard
parmi les huit états possibles mais la
probabilité d'avoir chacune des réponses
va dépendre des coefficients plus locaux
si on est élevé plus la réponse associé
sera probable si on fait la mesure
qu'une seule fois et bien on aura qu'une
réponse par exemple 011
mais on a le droit de recommencer sauf
qu'en mécanique quantique une mesure
détruit l'état superposés et donc il
faut reprendre depuis le début en
appliquant à nouveau le circuit
quantique
mais si on répète cette procédure plein
de fois et qu'on fait un histogramme
pour représenter combien de fois on a
obtenu cette réponse eh bien on aura
certaines réponses plus probable que
d'autres et ce d'autant plus que les
coefficients sont grands dans l'état
qu'on mesure faire ce genre de
manipulation c'est à dire appliquer un
circuit faire la mesure et recommencer
plein de fois c'est ce qu'on appelle
faire un échantillonnage du circuit
quantique
ce travail d'échantillonnage on peut
aussi le simuler avec un ordinateur
classique il existe des algorithmes qui
si on leur donne la description du
circuit quantique peuvent calculer
exactement ce qui va se passer dans le
processeur quantique c'est juste
potentiellement plus long mais faire ce
même calcul à la fois sur le processeur
quantique et sur un ordinateur classique
ça permet de faire deux choses d'une
part comparé les temps de calculs pour
voir de combien le processeur quantique
est plus rapide et d'autres par valider
que le processeur quantique a donné une
bonne réponse c'est à dire un
échantillonnage du circuit qui est
plausible bien alors venant dans le
détail à ce qu'a réalisé l'équipe de
google pour vous expliquer le principe
de l'échantillonnage de circle quantique
j'ai pris le cas simplifiée d'un
processeur quantique à 3 cubitt le
processeur conçu par google qui l'ont
appelée si camors possède 53 cubitt
voyez ici une image au microscope qu'il
représente 1 il fait environ deux
centimètres ce qui est essentiel c'est
que les 53 cubitt qu'il contient
fonctionnent ensemble comme un seul
objet quantique
on dit qu'ils sont intriqués et c'est ça
qui est difficile à faire c'est pas
juste des qubits les uns à côté des
autres
alors petite anecdote pourquoi 53 cubitt
et bien parce que dans le processeur il
y en a en fait 54 mais il se trouve
qu'un des qubits était dysfonctionnel et
donc ils n'ont pas pu l'utiliser
ça montre un truc intéressant c'est que
ce processeur ils en ont pas à 150
exemplaires 1 c'est une pièce unique qui
a dû être affreusement compliquée à
fabriquer et donc si un cube it ne
marche pas on va faire sens d'un point
de vue technologique les cubitt sont
réalisées avec ce qu'on appelle des
jonctions supraconductrice imaginer des
minuscules bobines de fil
supraconducteurs le tout étant refroidis
dans une grosse enceinte a seulement
mini kelvin donc 0,02 degré au dessus du
zéro absolu
cette température glaciale c'est à la
fois pour avoir l'effet supraconducteurs
mais aussi surtout parce que la
température détruit la superposition
dans les culs bits donc il faut garder
tout ça bien au froid pour minimiser les
erreurs de calcul à l'extérieur ce
processeur quantique est relié à toute
une électronique plus classique qui
permet de le piloter et de fer entre
autres deux choses premièrement
appliquer les portes quantique qu'on
souhaite et c'est ça qui en fait
vraiment un processeur programmable de
l'extérieur si vous imaginez un circuit
quantique de votre choix
eh bien on peut décider de l'appliquer
au processeur et deuxièmement effectuer
la mesure de l'état quand on a fini
d'appliquer le circuit pour obtenir une
réponse et la stocker dans un système
externe tout à l'heure dans mon exemple
à 3 cubitt lors d'une mesure la réponse
était un truc du genre 011 et y en avait
huit possibles dans le cas de sica morts
la réponse sera une chaîne de 53
caractère du genre 0 1 1 1 0 1 0 0 etc
et il n'y a pas loin de dix mille
milliards de chaînes différentes
possibles pour tester leurs processeurs
les chercheurs de google
on imaginait des circuits plus ou moins
complexe consistant en l'application
successives d'un bloc de portes
quantique que l'on répète un certain
nombre de fois on appelle ça les cycles
et donc plus le nombre de cycles est
élevé plus le circuit sera grand et plus
le calcul sera a priori difficile dans
le cas le plus extrême testé par google
avec 20 cycle pour le circuit il a fallu
à 6k morts 200 secondes pour répéter
l'opération un million de fois et donc
avoir un échantillonnage avec un million
de mesures et les chercheurs de google
ont calculé que pour faire la même chose
sur un superordinateur possédant un
million de coeur il aurait fallu dix
mille ans alors ça paraît très
impressionnant mais ça pose une question
s'ils ne peuvent justement pas faire le
calcul avec un ordinateur classique
comment ils savent le temps que ça
prendrait et surtout comment ils
s'assurent que le processeur quantique a
donné une bonne réponse et bien avant de
faire le cas super complexe dont on
vient de parler ils ont d'abord traiter
des cas plus simple pour lesquels on
pouvait faire la comparaison
il ya trois types de simplification
possible utiliser moins de qubits
utiliser des circuits avec moins de
cycle et enfin utiliser certains types
particuliers de circuits qui sont
simplifiées à bhl et qui se prête mieux
aux calculs sur un ordinateur classique
ils ont ainsi comparé des cas avec
seulement 14
cycle et un nombre de cubes itt allant
de 12 à 53 et également des cas à 53
cubitt avec un nombre variable de cycle
mais uniquement pour des circuits
simplifié à bhl et à chaque fois le
processeur quantique fonctionner comme
prévu et donc pour le cas le plus
complexe 53 cubitt 20 cycle et un
circuit quantique non simple et fiable
on peut donc légitimement penser que si
camors a correctement fonctionné
également pour faire les calculs
classiques correspondants et vérifier
les résultats dans les cas où c'était
possible
les chercheurs de google ont quand même
dû sortir l'artillerie lourde en
utilisant notamment le superordinateur
le plus puissant du monde appelait ce
mythe ainsi que pas mal de puissance des
serveurs cloud de google
cela a notamment permis de faire des
extrapolations sur les temps de calcul
et d'estimer que dans le cas le plus
complexe
une tâche équivalente aurait pris
environ dix mille ans sur un ordinateur
comme son mythe
petite précision mais importante quand
on parle de science ce travail a été
publié dans une revue scientifique la
revue nature et donc il a été soumis à
un travail d'évaluation par des
chercheurs extérieurs
ce n'est pas la garantie absolue que
tout soit correct mais c'est pour
souligner que cette annonce c'est pas
juste non plus un communiqué de presse
de google où il aurait raconté ce qu'ils
voulaient a au total que nous apprend ce
travail est bien déjà il montre que le
calcul quantique est possible il ya
encore des chercheurs qui n'étaient pas
convaincus que des processeurs quantique
puisse vraiment en pratique a mené à une
accélération est là bien c'est le cas
d'autre part cela montre que google
aurait atteint la fameuse suprématie
quantique c'est à dire que pour la
première fois de l'histoire un
processeur quantique a fait un calcul
qu'un ordinateur classique n'aurait pas
pu faire en un temps raisonnable
maintenant un point qu'il faut avoir en
tête c'est que cette notion de
suprématie quantique qui met en
compétition les processeurs quantique et
les ordinateurs classiques elle est
susceptible de changer au cours du temps
au fur et à mesure de l'évolution des
technologies et des algorithmes
c'est par exemple ce qu'a essayé de
montrer ibm au moment de l' annonce de
google
alors forcément ils sont en compétition
dont ibm a tout intérêt à essayer de me
miser et l'exploitent google et pour
faire ça ils ont écrit un article
argumentant que le calcul qui soi-disant
prendrait 10 mille ans d'après google
en fait il serait possible de le faire
en seulement trois jours si on utilise
un d'autres algorithmes alors c'est
intéressant de regarder de plus près et
de comprendre comment pour simuler le
calcul quantique sur un ordinateur
classique donc pour faire cette
comparaison on utilise normalement des
algorithmes qui sont assez sophistiqué
et qui comme toujours en algorithmique
sont le résultat d'un compromis entre
l'utilisation de la mémoire la ram est
celle du processeur et ibm a proposé un
truc radical c'est d'utiliser un max de
ram pour gagner du temps de processeurs
le superordinateur ce mythe dont j'ai
parlé et que google a utilisé c'est
justement ibm qui l'a fabriqué même s'il
appartient à un labo national américain
et sa mémoire ram c'est 250 millions de
giguère or il se trouve que 250 millions
de giga c'est à peu près la ram qu'il
faut pour socke est entièrement l'état
complet d'un processeur quantique à 53
cubitt et je voudrais déjà que vous
réalisiez l'ampleur de ce truc de dingue
le processeur sic a marre quand il est
dans un certain état quantique
cet état est une superposition des deux
puissances 50,3 état propre possible et
donc il faut autant de coefficients pour
le décrire complètement comme depuis 153
c'est à peu près 10 millions de
milliards pour juste stocker l'état
quantique de sica morts il faut toute la
rame du superordinateur seul mythe est
en fait si on fait ce choix radical de
prendre autant de ram
ibm a expliqué qu'on pouvait utiliser un
algorithme eu un peu moins subtile moins
gourmand en temps de calcul est donc
faire l'ensemble de l'opération en
seulement trois jours au lieu de dix
mille ans alors pourquoi pas mais
plusieurs commentaires là dessus
premièrement ils ont dit que c'était
possible ils l'ont pas encore fait le
superordinateur le plus puissant du
monde il n'est pas non plus en self
service à la demande
ensuite même si c'était vrai le
processeur sika mort serait quand même
toujours mille fois plus rapide et aussi
10 millions de fois moins gourmands en
énergie accessoirement mais surtout le
jour où google gagne ne serait ce que
quelques cuves et 1 10 ans 60 au lieu de
53 pour que la façon de faire dit bm
marche
il faudrait cent fois plus de ram dans
le super ordinateur donc même si
l'objection est intéressante elle n'est
forcément que très temporaire malgré
tout il faut le rappeler le problème qui
a résolu le processeur quantique sika
mort n'est à ce stade qu'un problème
relativement inutile
un sans répercussion directe à part
peut-être la génération de nombres
aléatoires ce qui peut avoir des
applications concrètes et surtout
retenez bien qu on est encore très loin
de pouvoir utiliser un tel processeur
quantique pour résoudre des problèmes
comme la décomposition au facteur
premier
la raison c'est que si camors fait
pleins pleins d'erreurs
en effet un kubitz est assez instable et
sensible à tout un tas de défauts de
fabrication et de perturbations
extérieures c'est pour ça qu'on les
refroidit à 20000 kelvin d'ailleurs et
quentin cubitt est perturbé sacré une
erreur de calcul les chercheurs de
google ont mesuré le taux d'erreur de
leur processeur c'est environ 0,2 pour
cent quand on applique une porte
quantique et 3% quand on effectue une
mesure alors c'est peu mais sur un
circuit composé de nombreuses portes et
bien ça s'accumule très vite dans un
problème comme l'échantillonnage de
circuits quantique c'est pas dramatique
on prend plein d'échantillons et si
certains sont faux ça ressort comme du
bruit mais on arrive quand même à
conclure certaines choses et c'est
d'ailleurs en quelque sorte l'évolution
de ce rapport signal sur bruit avec la
complexité des circuits qui a servi à
google à faire la démonstration du
fonctionnement de sica mort et pour un
algorithme comme l'algorithme de schorre
celui qui permet de factoriser dénombre
la moindre erreur et le calcul est ruiné
sika mort fait donc beaucoup trop
d'erreurs pour espérer pouvoir faire ça
pour progresser dans ce domaine on peut
faire deux choses la première c'est
améliorer le processeur pour qu'il soit
plus fiable plus robuste qu'il fasse
moins d'erreurs et là il ya un petit peu
de marge
la deuxième c'est d'utiliser ce qu'on
appelle des codes correcteurs d'erreurs
il s'agit de procédures de contrôle qui
permettent de repérer quand des erreurs
se produisent et de les corriger
c'est quelque chose qu'on fait déjà
depuis longtemps avec les processeurs
classiques 1 et qu'on peut faire aussi
avec les processeurs quantique
même s'il a fallu imaginer des codes
correcteurs spécifique un cantique le
plus connu étant dû aux mathématiciens
peter shore toujours lui qui décidément
a beaucoup oeuvré pour l'informatique
quantique
mais le problème de ces codes
correcteurs quantique c'est qu'il oblige
à multiplier le nombre de cubes it et
qu'ils sont incroyablement gourmands
pour vous donner une idée on peut
estimer que pour atteindre la suprématie
quantique en réussissant la
factorisation d'un très grand nombre
il faudrait un ordinateur quantique à
environ 2000 cubitt à condition que ceux
ci fonctionnent de façon parfaite 1 sans
jamais d'erreurs mais comme les cubis ne
sont
parfait on a besoin de codes correcteurs
quantique et on estime que pour pouvoir
les implémenter il faudrait plutôt
environ un milliard de qubits au lieu de
juste 2001 milliards de qubits et on en
est à 53
donc même en supposant que le nombre de
cubes it double tous les deux ans un peu
à la façon de la loi de moore pour
l'informatique classique et bien vous
voyez qu'on a encore un peu le temps de
voir venir
voilà merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo je
rappelle que j'en ai fait une autre qui
présente de façon un peu plus détaillé
les principes de l'ordinateur quantique
et que comme toujours vous pouvez
trouver des compléments et des
références dans le billet de blog qui
accompagne la vidéo comme toujours
abonné vous mettez la cloche tout ça les
actualités de la chaîne c'est sur
facebook et twitter
et je vous dis à bientôt pour une
nouvelle vidéo
[Musique]